one day I told my friend I was terribly  blue was it far too late to do what I  dreamed I could do he thought for a  moment then he answered he said the  rules don't apply to you he said it very  simply and quietly too but as if there  wasn't any doubt at all that he knew he  gave me a gift that I would treasure he  said the rules don't apply to you in the  movies we see in the shows on TV and in  anthems passionately style there's a  message that you've got to keep in  leaving in yourself but they generally  mean if you're young  is it writen in the air as it seems to  be that we haven't long at all to find  our destiny I'll always remember to be  grateful that the rules don't apply to  me I wouldn't lie  the rules don't apply the rules don't  apply  rated pg-13 in theaters November 23rd  what are you doing you've got a driver's  license don't you let's go